if anything, it is for having generated me cases in the
light lives on Sunday yes we pray
for those who have disabilities
without party who listens to the cry of the
poor that on all sides those young
mobile lives you think they sing to death
from the indifference generated by politics
is none of yours  children
the work and the necessary for an
honest life and we come together saying
sir help us to do your
new york sir help us to do your
will
in times of difficulty and visco
whirling hopes in moments of suffering
in moments of more than usually
help you  paternoster cuisine celis
santificetur nomentum a merci a train
youtube fiat voluntas tua sicut in heaven
and ti in terra pane nostrum daily da
nobis hodie et di mitte nobis debita
nostra sicut et nos of myths mousses
debtors bus nostris etnìe no
induce yes into temptation free seat  nos a malo
amen
[Music]
second station jesus takes the cross
penn station
[Music]
laura secolare reneghi  himself
take his cross sir it is easy to carry the
crucifix around the neck or hang it as an
ornament on the walls results of
our beautiful cathedrals but it is not
so easy to meet
recognize the rhythms new crosses
staring eyes only the homeless of
young people without hope without work  and with
no
good prospects that tics over immigrants win
forced to live in shacks on the
fringes of our society
after having faced in an insecure
unfortunately having these
unsafe camps are burned and
razed along with the dreams and
hopes of thousands of marginalized women
so many  children are then discriminated against
because of their origin an image
of the color of their skin up from their
social class
how many mothers are humiliated to
see their children de risi and excluded
from the opportunities of their peers and
schoolmates
thank you sir  because you
gave us the example with your own life
those fans c  he manifests solutions
towards enemies or simply towards those who
are lord jesus
how many times we too be nice
larepubblica.it aims we choose
declared absolutely yours to follow them
in tails and if but it was not as
easy and to pull it when I spoke to
serve families repeat themselves i
enemies sounds airlines
help us brent passes through me wars
always our life epps at the service of
others
help us hope when we feel
abandoned both a band since
difficult follows no riesi tiff or
like when service for others
paternoster cuisine celis
santificetur nomentum avenia terrain  youtube fiat
voluntas your sicut in heaven and you on
earth our bread a newspaper of nobis
hatred and mitte nobis debita nostra
sicut et nos of myths mousse debtors bus
nostris et in our dukas in
temptation free seat nos a malo
amen
[Music]
[Music  ]
third station jesus falls the first time
from trip station we move to venice
[Music]
he is loaded  o our sorrows lord
jesus on the steep road 1 that brings the
ordeal modest and wanted to
experience fragility ostrich spies the weak have
never lacked what the church today would be
like without the presence and
generosity of so many volunteers of our
new samaritans of the third millennium in
one cold night in january ministers on
a street on the outskirts of rome three
Africans little more than little girls
crouched on the ground warmed
their young half-naked body around
a brazier some young men to
have fun
passing by car and threw
flammable material on the fire,
severely burning them in  that same
increase passed one of the many
ding sparse units of volunteers who
rescued them and took her to the hospital and
then welcomed them in a family home
how long it was and will be necessary
for those girls to heal not
only from the burns of the limbs but
also from the pain  and from humiliation then
find yourself with a muted body  hilate is
forever disfigured
lady we thank you for the presence
of so many new Samaritans we
still live the experience of our
mister marked by eternal unity soul and
we are excited that not too many times
today we claim our rights and
interests lady do us the  grace not to
remain insensitive 20 then away from
their sufferings
through we met
let us pray together saying
help us from me when demanding to
be also ps when a lady does not want
paternoster cuisine celis
santificetur nome into adveniat rain
youtube fiat voluntas tua sicut in cielo
et in terra pax  ostro a newspaper a
da nobis hodie e ti di mitte nobis
debita nostra sicut ethnos of myths
mousse debtors bus nostris e ne
no induce sin temptation free seat nos
a malo
amen
[Music]
fourth station jesus meets mary his
mother station will pierce the  soul
so that they are revealed old
simeon had foretold you when you introduced
the little one  jesus at the temple for the rite
of purification would have pierced
now it's time to renew your
fiat his vision at the will of the
father to accompany a son to the gallows
dix treated like a criminal
have mercy on the tables too many mothers in
them have let theirs go
young daughters to
europe hoping to help their
families
all pa in extreme poverty while they
found every humiliation contempt united
my photo also people as a young man
brutally killed on the street
leaving a trinity of a few months
lilin foot chargers maria right
now you  live the same drama and other
prawns movement you xperia pro numero
fileni and who have left for other
countries
open with the future in purple for
them and their families but who unfortunately
find refined humiliations of
violent morrison france make indifference
solitude grandmother ines and even  the death
for the 20 years from one of their strengths that
frank sicav orange we pray together  eme
saying and makes us know how to give
comfort to console the hands for those who
in life who suffer every day and
20%
paternoster cuisine celis
santificetur nomentum adveniat Regno un tool fiat
voluntas tua sicut in heaven and you on
earth
pane nostrum daily a da  nobis
hodie et di mitte nobis debita nostra
sicut et nos of myths mousse debtors bus
nostris and holding in dukas in
temptation free seat nos a malo
amen
[Music]
fifth station the circus your helps
jesus brought for tiziana laura
manzato is brought so sir  Jesus
on the way to Calvary did you feel the
weight of bringing back that rough wooden cross in
vain unwanted in the gesture of
help from a friend of one of
your disciples 9 oct the sets of one of the
many common people whose
suffering she relieved unfortunately only  an
unknown air lines simone di cirene
for public gold obligation who gave
a hand tour.it where the new
cyrenians of the third legn are today  o where we
find them i
would like to recall at ringo peak
the experience of a group of religious
of different nationalities of
Armenian origin and belonging tv with whom
for over 17 years
every Saturday we visit a center
for immigrant women without  documents
women often young women of waiting
to know their fate in the balance
between expulsion and the possibility of staying
when the suffering we encounter but
also when it is joyful in these women to
find themselves in front of religious women
from their countries who speak
languages come hickeys dry their
tears that share moments of
prayer and celebration that make it less
hard in the long months spent between
iron bars and concrete asphalts
together for all the Cyrenians of our
history so that nothing is ever
aware that welcoming the last
of the night
we welcome ladies when we are tired
when we hear the months when he asks us
about carige we see we suffer
paternoster  cuisine celis sancti feature
nomentum adveniat Regno un tool fiat
voluntas tua sicut in cielo et in terra
pax our daily life a da nobis hate e
di mitte nobis debita nostra sicut et
nos timi teamus debitori bus nostris e
te ne nos in dukas in temptation
free seat nos  badly
amen
[Music]
sixth station test the ironic excuse the
face of jesus
[Music]
all you have done to one
we think of the children in various parts of the
world who cannot go to school and
who are instead exploited, sold and
bought  on the scene traffickers of
human flesh exploits including our streets
by many Christians including who have
lost the sense of their own and others'
sacredness like a minor with a small
body met one night in Rome
that men aboard luxurious cars
queued do not exploit puts
the  pil pur of age could have the age
of their daughters what imbalance
this violence can create in the lives of
many young people only sorprus is experienced
i the arrogance and indifference of
click spirin of grandparents god and by day
I was cans you look for the defenseless do you want to
throw them back on the street a
next merchant become street and that
is spread sir jesus make
our eyes clear because we know how to find out
will say your  today I face our brothers
and sisters
only a few corners of the
world languages children deprived of the right to a chi
dhood more read rai schoo
education and jackie chan to the i
nocence of science creatures used as cheap
goods indulgence the ice with géra
d at will  to enzo sir
please have tip is sick and
help us to rediscover how
human beings mb created believe
and image esse billions
mike ness we pray together with cells
look for ladies help us to the beautiful
successes ladies help us to ourselves the
face  di e the social injustices itself
and the dignity that the person wards will bring to
be tahrir i comes equal to style
paternoster here is sin celis san  tificetur
nomentum avenia reign a tool fiat
voluntas tua sicut in heaven and you on
earth but in our daily life a da
nobis hatred and mitte nobis debita
nostra sicut et nos of myths mousse
debtors bus nostris etnìe nos in dukas
in temptation free seat nos a malo
amen
[Music]
seventh station of the second insulted he
did not respond with evils but he got
to the ass that in our time judges
the present society to people of great
value over they lose to the ground
par excellence ghost those funerals for the
wounds foundation of peace and of
human coexistence but suspended in a
society where forgiveness is experienced as
weak the gentleman asks us not to
stop at appearances and you do not do it with
the words harris but with the example we
two to those who torment you you answer
turkish beyond the  pursued knowing full well
that true justice can never
be based on hate gestures and payton
and tweets enable
us to ask for schepper and
give father forgive them p  because
they do not know what they are doing
go towards khartoum padana you have felt
the weight of the condemnation of the
mandono the suffering inflicted by
mobile phone embroidery happens the meeting had
abandoned you found the car remains a
delusion to do it
today walk on the guardianship
[Music]
let's see together saying sir priest
give comfort to those who feel offended
paternoster cuisine celis santificetur
nomentum adveniat rain youtube fiat
voluntas tua sicut in cielo e ti in
terra
pane nostrum daily a da nobis hatred
and mitte nobis debita nostra se i
could not di miti mousse  debtors bus
nostris etnìe nos induce in temptation
free seat nos a malo
amen
[Music]
eighth station jesus meets women
state station jeans while francesca
armogida giovanni giuliani that children of
jerusalem
do not cry over tare you will eat and south
yorkshire run the social
economic situation and  politics of migrants
and victims of trafficking in human beings
but questions us and us nuns who  we
must have the courage as
dad francesco spot strongly states to
denounce the trafficking of human beings
everything is worth a crime against humanity
all of us especially Christians
must grow up in the conscious at
home and steve gadd we are responsible for the
problem
and we all joke and  dublino foo be part
of the solution for everyone but above all
we women are required to challenge
courage the courage to know if
I would like to act individually and as a
community only by putting together
our house polarities and if they can
become a great wealth and well-being.
to change the mentality
and to alleviate the sufferings of manila
if prof
the form I got a foreigner the
different must not be seen as an
enemy to be rejected no to the white lace
in vain harlot ctim but rather
taken with my brother or a sister
amazed to welcome and  to help
them are not a problem but a
precious resource for ours
strong armored tables where the well-being
and consultants do not alleviate the growing
lies in the slides and fatigue ladies
teach us to have your gaze that
look of welcome and mercy the
baskets to create if it were we pray
together saying with those who suffer from
death it also makes more effort
paternoster  here is sin celis
santificetur nomentum adveniat Regno un tool fiat
voluntas tua sicut in cielo et in terra
pax nostrum newspaper da nobis odi et
di mite nobis debita nostra sicut et nos
of myths mousse debtors bus nostris e te
ne nos in dukas in temptation
free seat  nos a malo
amen
[Music]
ninth station penalty intelligence had
mistreated and not April penalty and rasponi
lamb with two lady for the third
time if he fell exhausted and a billion
under the weight of the colongi happy and
just like so many girls forced
on the streets by groups  of slave traffickers in the
mirror endure the
fatigue and humiliation of seeing
their young body and ke  ynote
manipulated years accused destroyed the
myths together with them ayane paris those
young women and they feel like
doubled and saw to one side look for is
used is side by side the book and
condemned by a society that refuses to
see this type of exploitation in
content  used by the statement that the
measure does not remain tailor itcz of the
many nights spent on the streets in rome
off I was looking for a young woman recently
not seeing her in his group I called her
insistently about the arrival of percy and
that with my car in the short crouched silos it
is  asleep on the side
of the road with my call to
facebook wakes up ten themes she said
she couldn't do it pc enemy I won only
sunni I repeated congo a piece someone
if she knew that tripit what
happened to her daughter would cry when
the two ladies are over how many times she
addressed us  this awkward question
where is your brother remembered as a
gray one among plants and reached films to
share his pr  esa and the humiliation
of so many people to close up and afi and
easy touch with to resist
visit our future it is not as
easy chileans that is space taken as you
live jobs as governs valens and also
as anita christians
we pray together of ash net that
aziz  and sweet strength and courage to
announce one brings us courage
to face the emptying and the lived
bending hands but does not even go out and
to the silence of mad men the front of the
ginjou room who no one is there paternoster
santificetur nome adveniat Regno un tool
fiat  voluntas tua sicut in heaven and ti in
terra
pane nostrum daily from nobis hatred and
of mitte nobis debita nostra sicut et
nos of myths mousse debtors bus nostris
et de nos in dukas in temptation
free seat nos a malo
amen
[Music]
tenth station jesus for  one hundred and hated
of his golden chances christine therefore
of feeling one of mansur ines
remains in nimes money well-being power
are the idols of all time also es
especially of ours which is evaluated
of the enormous steps forward in the
recognition of human rights
9 assist me the indies and including the
body of minors day and robbed
of their dignity report and to their
future miners we have forgotten the
centrality of the human being his
tell me grand central dell'efsa forza ttp
while walls and barriers are rising in the world we
want to remember and thank those
who with different leacock roles in
recent months have risked their
own militant spas particularly
in the mediterranean sea to save that
of many families in search  security
and opportunity sormani feminis human
beings you are on the run poverty dictatorships a
banes mouthwash nor ict
corruption help us lady to rediscover
the beauty and wealth that every
person and every people who scafari
maria reach passive interests and
we pray so that tourism
teaching of humiliation maria
living a little more kristen p  let's regale
together says black species that then there is
a heart full of mustapha dodgers
lady no to the memories in front of the
life of the glass and of tomorrow in front
of 20 30 the wake in front of the mini to the
interests in person in san francesco and
a dinner  the heart full of mercy
paternoster cuisine celis
santificetur nomentum adveniat Regno un tool fiat
voluntas tua sicot in heaven et in terra
pax our daily life a da nobis hatred
and mitte no views vitanostra sicut
ethnos of myths mousse debtors bus
nostris et nos in dukas in temptation
sade libero nos a malo
amen
[Music]
eleventh station jesus and the trend
is used on mc è retta and easy kyoto is
[Music]
father and vane because they don't know the
favorite one born to you that our
society proclaims equality
directs a practice  and tolerates the
tech inequality that earthquakes raise to
even the most extreme forms in
action children are bought and sold as
slaves by the new markets of being a
biden i  three victims of trafficking are
then exploited victims for three years in the
city as commodities without state peace
how many get rich by devouring the
flesh and blood of the poor cloning
rich lady and how many people still
today have been nailed to a cross
victims of exploitation  di romano
ameni della liberty future expo their
cry for help and ashes as a government and
how it is
a heart because unlike many
people who are still nailed
to
happiness today we pray together saying for the
new powerful paternoster cuisine celis
santificetur name into avenia
united kingdom fiat voluntas tua sicut in cielo
et in terra pax our daily a da
nobis hate e di mitte nobis debita
nostra sicut et nos of myths mousse
debtors bus nostris and keeping in
dukas in temptation free seat nos a
malo
amen
[Music]
twelfth station  jesus dies on the
society in class of my house is
elisabetta my god my god why not
maybe helped that you too are  ignore you
felt on the cross the weight of the
screen bzu of derision triggering
the insults of violence and
the abandonment of indifference and
indifference only mary your mother was
places disciples of uim
the witnesses you of your suffering
of your death their example there
inspire medera to commit ourselves not
to make those who
suffer the object of too many ordeals feel lonely and
scattered around the world including the
collection fields and among similar camps with the
countries of translator it
if the ships to which a safe harbor is recited
the long  bureaucratic negotiations
for the final destination of the
cies and the detention centers were destined the
hot spots the fields for
seasonal workers lady please
help us get close to the new
crusaders while freeing up our
time to fish their purchases and
make it together
help our lives to those who have suffered
injustices slander
paternoster cuisine celis
santificetur nomentum adveniat  kingdom a tool fiat
voluntas tua sicut in heaven and you on
earth
pane nostrum daily from nobis hatred
and mitte nobis debita nostra sicut et
nos of myths mousse debtors bus nostris
and keeping in dukas in temptation
free seat nos a malo
amen
[Music]
thirteenth  station
if the grain of wheat who remembers in
this era of news burned
quickly those 26 Nigerian young people the
[Music]
funerals were celebrated hard and
first the crossing of the Sahara desert
piled up on makeshift buses then
the forced stop of the scary
collection centers in libya finally the jump
where they found death at the gates
of the promised land of the ip in the seas
two of them carried you tone
of a new strange shape in their wombs girls
will never see the light of rice  but their
death like that of jesus taken down from the
cross was never all these lives
we entrust to the mercy of our father
but above all mother of the poor for
lord i  n the police station
we hear once again the
cry that father francesco I
evoke her from lampedusa
indeed we continue to those we have in
front of those coffins lined up by a rose they
ask us to know responsibility and
we pray together sir help us to
share the tears in the face of the
sufferings of others  leafs in front of bari
in front of crying
the weeping paternoster wiess in chains
santificetur nomentum adveniat rain
youtube fiat voluntas tua sicut in heaven
and ti in terra pane nostrum daily a
da nobis hatred and mitte nobis debita
nostra sicut et nos of myths mousse
debtors  bus nostris e te ne no
induce si into temptation free seat nos
a malo
amen
[Music]
fourteenth station n is finished and
the desert the seas have become the new
cemeteries of today in front of these
deaths together there are no answers there
are prof  responsibility brothers entities
that let other brothers,
men, women, children who we have not
been able or wanted blood to die while i  governments
argue closed in the palaces of power
the will be filled with skeletons of
people the experts could not resist
the fairy cost the new exodus how much
cruelty is raging on chivu in of
voyages of despair
anti queering and torture with two
marines transformed into contempt nice hand
stroke in tones now ac understand epics
we are all children of the same father
may the love of the nations of the
legislatures
well a three managers noster like alias
in celis santificetur nomentum avenia
Regno un tool fiat voluntas tua sicut in
heaven and you in earth
pane nostrum daily  da nobis hodie
et di mitte nobis debita nostra will be
quoted no estimi teamus debitori bus
nostris an no induce yes in temptation
free seat nos a malo
amen
[Music]
we would like to remember the story of the
nine-month-old girl who did not
leave nigeria  together with his young
parents and peppers in search of a
better future euro during the long and
dangerous journey in the medite  rraneo and
angels mum and dad who cute
died together with hundreds of other
people who had relied on
unscrupulous traffickers or never
to be able to reach the touching promised land
can only faver and survivors
fera she will also be he like moses
his was saved  life becomes a
light of hope in the journey
towards humanity more at the end of your via
crucis
we pray you ladies who have you to whoever
can as a brother has recognized himself in
his dignity of ends
by help in your light of people
hungry only for the elderly who  find the
doors of hearts small calculations in the
homes of broken families
see the man learn of mayor massaro
the consecrated the cross of your children who
believing numerous photos of your church
what is his gospel that
from inside our common home
class  seriously lord jesus
is that the last arrival be with you
be blessed the name of the lord
our help in the name of the lord
good life god omnip  otente father son and
holy spirit
and now my so
[Music]
no
or
[Music]
and tourists